sur de la part des journalistes qui
aiment pas entendre que ça va pas qu'ils
n'aiment pas entendre que le nouveau
président
a été mal élu que et ces femmes ont donc
il faut il faut bien penser il faut être
politiquement correct est là
je l'étais pas je l'étais pas sur la
croissance je disais que
c'était parce que
l'économiste maison avait prévu et que
ça donc il ya des choses qui qui passent
pas et puis je suis pas le premier 1
olivier berruyer avant moi a été sortie
d'edf m charles gave n'est plus invitée
moi je peux inviter
on aille en aura d'autres qui suivront
je pense c'est une stérilisation de la
parole économique oms à les stériliser
depuis longtemps donc c'est pas
la parole économique n'a jamais été
libre et ça et cela depuis longtemps
donc c'est de la communication on vous
dit ce que ce que vous devez entendre et
surtout pas de choses qui fâchent donc
on vous présente c'est du marketing pur
on vous présente des chiffres
qui sont à la limite de la mini de la
manipulation c'est à dire que on vous
donne le le chiffre qui va bien alors
sur le chômage on vous donne la
catégorie ya sachant pertinemment que
baisser des montants et puis on vous dit
ah mais oui mais regardez on a fait
baisser le chômage sur la catégorie a
c'est vrai
ou d'un moment quand même à force d'en
sortir est de les mettre en stage
ou de les mettre en formation ou de les
sortir complètement des rôles ont fini
par avoir un une catégorie a qui
baissent et puis toutes les autres
montent et ça on oublie de le dire aux
etats unis c'est pareil la participation
à la population active
diminue est au plus bas
et on vous annonce un chiffre qui est
proche du plein emploi
tout ça pour justifier les politiques
économiques et et les politiques
monétaires et on oublie de vous dire que
en gros si vous retraités ce chiffre
vous êtes probablement entre 18 et 20 %
de gens qui ne travaillent pas alors
après si vous voulez pas les appeler
chômeurs moi personnellement ça me
chagrine pas mais qui ne travaillent pas
et qui dépendent de l'état et qui
devrait travailler qui sont en âge de
travailler qui pourraient travailler qui
ne travaillent pas ce que c'est avait en
plus ce qui est amusant c'est qu'on vous
donne à chaque fois un chiffre brut et
on oublie de de vous on oublie de
creuser on oublie de regarder ce qu'il
ya derrière ces chiffres parce que
vous avez des gens qui par exemple en
allemagne ou consistant à en exemple
qu'on vire des chiffres du chômage alors
que c'est des gens qui ont travaillé
deux heures dans moi donc deux heures à
10 10 euros ça fait pas lourd quand même
pour vivre donc
et tous et tous et
tous et toutes ces catégories de
personnes qui sont temps partiel au lieu
d'être à temps plein aux etats-unis
c'est effrayant c'est à dire que depuis
quasiment
tous les emplois qui ont été créés à 90%
sont des emplois à temps partiel et pas
des emplois à temps plein il ya même il
ya eu poursuites depuis 2008 2009 de
licenciement de
contrat à durée indéterminée et à temps
plein pour réengager des gens à temps
partiel alors ya des gens qui ont deux
trois boulots
qui sont évidemment mal payés quand vous
avez un emploi à temps partiel vous avez
à des salaires qui sont 20% inférieurs
j'aimerais qu'on vienne sur
l'interprétation des chiffres est-ce que
c'est pas nécessaire que nos politiques
ou nos leaders d'opinion et une vision
avec des lunettes roses un peu chaud
c'est pour pouvoir donner un peu de
courage
de l'énergie aux gens parce que si on
leur présente la réalité des chiffres
tels que vous pouvez l'apercevoir
est-ce que ça les découragerait pas est
ce qu'il ne serait enfin j'ai pas c'est
pas pour moi c'est un c'est un des
principes de la m démocratie c'est de
voter pour quelqu'un en connaissance de
cause si on vous arrange le tableau vous
votez pourquoi
vous savez pas ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et pourquoi on ne sait pas
ce qui se passe c'est pourquoi l'état
fait en sorte qu'on ne sache pas ce qui
se passe c'est pour qu'on les pende pas
place publique c'est tout c'est pour
éviter qu'on ressorte les trucs du passé
vous savez le truc qui tombe et qui
tranchait la tête c'est c'est pour ça
c'est pour que j'ai toujours dit depuis
longtemps un mouton si vous voulez le
tondre il faut pas qu'ils bougent et
bien
on fait en sorte que vous ne bougez pas
pour pouvoir vous tondre plus facilement
notre proverbe sur les moutons c'est à
force d'agir comme des moutons on finit
toujours la gorge tranchée par exemple
on va revenir un petit peu sur la zone
euro qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur
l'europe
sur l'europe c'était amusant j'ai un
j'ai fait une émission avec frais d'état
dit sur europe 1 il ya il ya quelques
jours
où je me suis retrouvé justement avec
des dés sachant
pas des savants des sachants donc qu'ils
sont tous profs d'ailleurs tous
professeurs dans différents
établissements et qui sont des
économistes et des économistes qui
conseillent les politiques qui conseille
les dirigeants économiques et
c'est là que vous prenez conscience que
l'on s'en sortira pas ce qu'ils ont un
discours qui est surréaliste à dire
qu'ils sont hors sol sont hors sol ils
vous disent ils commencent toutes leurs
phrases par on sait que
moi je j'aurais tendance à commencer et
paye mes phrases par je ne sais rien
mais eux ils savent
parce qu'il ya eu des études qui ont été
faites
et alors il vous sortent des choses
totalement fausse mais avec une
assurance extraordinaire en vous disant
par exemple que les chefs d'entreprises
ce qui ne sont pas ce que je suis en
revanche les chefs d'entreprise ils
investissent quand les taux baissent non
un chef d'entreprise n'investit pas
quand les taux baissent un chef
d'entreprise il investit quand il avait
commandes quand il a dû business
visibilité et laissez pas le fait que
les taux passe de 1 à 0,5 ou de 2 à 1
qui vont faire investir mais ça ils ont
toujours pas compris ils vivent sur des
choses comme ça alors il était fou de
joie parce que
il ya un petit rebond de croissance
en europe
mais qui est un gir à un fort rebond de
croissance pourquoi
d'abord parce que
dans tous les dans tous les pays on a la
même pratique c'est à dire un déficit
budgétaire
explosif
peut-être nécessaire mais peut-être
nécessaire non pas nécessaire c'est à
dire que
si vous demandez à un chef d'entreprise
si à chaque fois qu'il veut faire un
euro de chiffre d'affaires il faut
qu'ils m 5 euros de dettes
ça va pas le faire rigoler longtemps
d'accord il faut savoir que la dette
c'est la dette d'état c'est de l'impôt
différé c'est de l'impôt que vous
paierez plus tard donc on peut pas vous
dire à la fois je vais investir
aujourd'hui l'investissement ne se
faisant qu'avec de l'est puisqu'on est
déjà surendettés donc je vais investir
aujourd'hui et je vais baisser les
impôts c'est pas vrai
forcément vous aurez des impôts puisque
c'est de l'impôt la dette c'est de
l'impôt mais ce qui est juste décalé
dans le temps donc
c'est une c'est une star mensonge alors
aujourd'hui vous avez
un petit rebond mais limite faudrait là
j'ai pas j'ai pas regarder en détail
mais je pense que c'est ça devrait être
assez amusant c'est souvent l'épaisseur
du trait c'est à dire qu'on vous annonce
un 0 4% sur un trimestre et alors 0 4%
sachez que sur un trimestre ça fait du
1,6 parce qu'on vous annonce pas 0,4 on
vous annonce ainsi ce annualisé d'accord
et donc qu'on vous dit c'est génial on
est sur un 6 1 8% de croissance mais si
c'est 1 8% de croissance avec 5% de
déficit budgétaire excusez moi mais
c'est de la croissance
entre guillemets acheter mais qu'il
faudra payer plus tard or aujourd'hui
c'est le modèle et c'est le modèle
mondial c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
n'avait pas de croissance sans dettes
alors il ya un des intervenants chez
taddeï de l'oif c'est eux qui dis avec
toute façon il n'y a pas de croissance
sans dette mais
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que on
peut pas aujourd'hui
avoir la moindre croissance il faut pas
mettre trois quatre cinq fois de dettes
en face
excusez moi mais on va jusqu'où là comme
ça comment on fait on va avoir on a un
potentiel de croissance en europe qui
est entre 0 et 1 on a un potentiel de
croissance aux états unis qui est allée
un ennemi
on fait comment on fait comment quand on
est endetté à
dette dette publique plus dette privée
on est à 300 350 % du pib comment on
fait
on ne peut pas donc aujourd'hui on est
coincé c'est à dire qu'on est obligé de
cette espèce de course en avant
perpétuelle cavalerie 2 toujours plus
exactement de toujours plus de dettes
mais la cavalerie c'est du pénal dans le
privé un sale et pas pour l'état
heureusement pour lui parce que sinon
ils seraient tous en prison mais c'est
quand même du pénal et d'un donc
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas s'arrêter on
est obligé de continuer comme ça à vitam
aeternam et qu'elle est calé le le geek
elle est la fin de l'histoire la fin de
l'histoire c'est quoi ont fait défaut
tous on les sort peut-être que classe
moyenne avant et c'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire c'est à dire que aux
états unis il ya plus de casse moyenne
donc que vous avez des très riches et
puis les parrish du tout des pauvres en
europe on est en train de faire la même
chose donc il y a or si vous voulez on
peu pas email on ne peut pas reposer sur
les 0,01 pour cent de la population
qui finalement on capte tout c'est pas à
eux ils vont pas ils vont pas acheter
200 voitures ils en auront 3 et puis
vont s'arrêter là ils vont pas manger de
100 fois plus comment donc personne et
que vous percevez l'allemagne
comment je perçois l'allemagne c'est
l'allemagne a énormément profité 1 de
l'euro
de l'allemagne à
là dessus a à a énormément profité de
mesures qui ont été mises en place il ya
une quinzaine d'années et qui consistait
à aa baissé les salaires et
abc les heures de travail ce qui a fait
que ils ont ils ont été beaucoup plus
compétitifs ils ont réformé beaucoup de
choses ils ont un modèle qui est
extrêmement exportateurs comme le modèle
japonais c'est l'allemagne c'est un
petit japon c'est un petit japon avec en
termes démographiques eux
vingt ans de moins que le japon à peu
près c'est à dire c'est plus l'allemagne
c'est le japon des années 90
et le
l'allemagne à un problème démographique
exactement comme le japon sur ce qu'ils
ont fait ils ont fait rentrer un million
de réfugiés mais là c'est une erreur
c'est une erreur fatale de madame merkel
pourquoi parce que quand vous fait
rentrer des réfugiés
alors oui ils ont essayé de nous vendre
que c'était tous des ingénieurs des
médecins
malheureusement ce n'était pas ce
n'était pas vraiment le cas et si vous
voulez là ça devient des coûts parce que
qu'est-ce que vous faites quand le
réfugié arrive il n'y a pas de boulot
donc on lui donne c'est de l'assistanat
on lui donne de quoi manger et c'est
donc de la bête que on emploie pour pour
lui donner de quoi vivre et et
malheureusement il crée pas de richesse
si vous voulez donc excusez moi mais est
on est en train de s'en apercevoir quand
vous voyez ongs et l'américaine se
féliciter sur la loi travail française
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de la loi
travail mais c'est la transposition des
dd
des directives européennes donc en fait
c'est ce que je j'ai dit depuis le début
c'est à dire que monsieur macron est un
président d'opérette une marionnette
avec
le vrai le vrai président de tout ça
c'est madame merkel
c'est normal c'est elle qu'il est qu'
alice ou
c'est elle qui commande et est donc en
europe
aujourd'hui c'est elle qui commande
alors on peut pas comme le dit monsieur
macron récupérer sa souveraineté
on n'a pas de souveraineté on est aux
ordres de madame merkel
donc
c'est la bce qui dirige chez madame
merkel qui dirige et sais pas monsieur
macron jeu macron est une aimable
marionnettes quand on voit le portugal
avec des chiffres de croissance
extraordinaire
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on peut on
penser aller c'est toujours la même
chose c'est s'il voulait c'est c'est se
sont bien remis du portugais non non ils
s'en sont pas bien remis le portugal est
toujours en faillite le portugal a
toujours une dette hallucinante
comme la grèce a toujours une dette
hallucinante et on vous dit ça y est
c'est en train de se redresser non ça
s'est pas redressée vous n'avez pas de
croissance en grèce vous n'avez pas
finalement de croissance en espagne est
ce que c'est de la croissance acheté par
du déficit budgétaire en plus je vous
rappelle quand même que mon amie on a
intégré
quand même ce qui a été calculé en 2010
il n'y a pas eu de calcul nouveau enfin
on peut penser que la proportion est la
même sinon supérieure vous avez
l'intégration c'est ça qui est
merveilleux vous avez l'intégration
en 2014 vous avez l'intégration dans les
chiffres du pibe de l'espagne de la
prostitution et la drogue c'est quand
même hallucinant qu'on en soit arrivé là
tout de même nom donc on intègre ça ce
qui veut dire que en gros c'est au doigt
mouillé un je te mets ce que je veux
puisque par définition on ne sait pas
encore on les connaît pas les chiffres
donc on vous colle ça et ça représente
quand même l'air de rien pour l'espagne
en tout cas en 2010 0,8 à 0,9 pour cent
du pib pas rien d'accord donc là si vous
voulez vous donner des chiffres en
criant victoire en espagne je sais pas
si vous êtes allés en descente ugl
récemment non mais c'est la même chose
au portugal vous êtes vous êtes
aujourd'hui dans des dents des
dans des pays qui oui alors vont avoir
un sursaut de croissance parce que ils
ont
[Musique]
fait peser sa sur les salaires extra et
donc ils ont eu un petit peu plus de
boulot mais c'est ponctuel ça va ça va
durer un an et au bout d'un an on
retrouvera les mêmes problèmes par ce
biais mais pendant un stock de dette qui
est juste ahurissant et que vous ne
pourrez pas remboursé de toute façon
pendant ce temps là admettons que ces
chiffres permettent de d'avoir une
bouffée d'air frais au niveau de
l'économie peut-être une start up va
réussir à se développer peut-être que
c'est l'idée du futur c'est peut-être se
donner des chances de se redéployer ou
de se déployer dans un nouveau secteur
d'activité je me fais l'avocat du diable
mais bien sûr demain
le nouveau google et portugais aucun
souci gauche ce que vous y croyez vous
même nom donc non c'est
ridicule à chaque fois on nous a dit ça
on nous avait dit les banques centrales
imprime des billets parce que elle gagne
du temps et que on peut espérer que
pendant ce temps là il va y avoir des
réformes il va y avoir tout d'un coup un
truc extraordinaire qu'elle annonce
accueillie continue ses injections de
liquidités will bien sûr non c'est loin
ils y croient et non faussée pas s'il y
croit le pauvre
il dit surtout beaucoup de bêtises
monsieur draghi a par exemple dit
dernière fois que il
remettait une
prolonger son curieux parce que ils
étaient déçus par les chiffres
d'inflation le corps le quantitative
easing c'est déflationniste donc studio
donc plus lent mettra plus ça sera
déflationniste c'est complètement idiot
donc maintenant ils sont embarqués dans
quelque chose qui ne peuvent pas sur
lequel ils peuvent pas revenir en
arrière pourquoi tout simplement parce
que les banques centrales ont depuis
2008 2009 1er cuve américain les banques
centrales y acheter tout le marché
c'est elle qui fixe les prix du marché
et c'est elle qui achète tous les
marchés mais non seulement les marchés
obligataires aussi les marchés actions
or que je sache dans aucun statut de
banque centrale il n'est marqué qu'une
banque centrale doit s'amuser à faire
mais mu sur des au tf ou sur des actions
c'est pas leur métier peut-être qu'elle
s'élargisse leur champ d'action disons
c'est nécessaire pour la stabilité de
l'euro et non mais ça là c'est pas c'est
pas pour la stabilité de je parle de
toutes les banques centrales qui
aujourd'hui achète les marchés ce qui
fait quoi ce qui fait quand vous achetez
les marchés quand vous en avez en
proportion à un bon pourcentage du pib'
voir le pipe pour certains je vous
rappelle banque nationale suisse par
exemple 115% du pib
le japon c'est 100% et c'est donc quand
vous achetez les marchés vous devenez
dépendant de qui des chiffres
économiques ou des marchés non des
marchés donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui ils sont terrorisés
dans toutes les banques centrales parce
qu'ils savent que s'ils arrêtent
le jeu est fini les marchés retombe et à
ce moment là ils font des pertes
colossales
donc c'est un jeu que vous ne pouvez pas
arrêter pourquoi les politiques ce sens
par pas de ce sujet là
d'abord
le niveau des politiques et abyssalement
bas donc il faudrait quand même le
progrès la république la soeur de la
reine sort du système financier un petit
peu sort de huit centièmes présence des
présidents de la république étaient en
général banquier chez rothschild pour
faire du private equity vous savez ce
qu'il faut pour le private equity il
faut un joli carnet c'est tout vous
demande pas d'être un technicien on vous
demande surtout pas d'être intelligent
on demande juste de mettre en présence
de personnes
voulaient pas se rouler par terre parce
que monsieur macron a fait un bref
passage dans une banque où il a dû
passer son temps dans des déjeuners en
princesse ça n'a aucun intérêt donc ne
qualifions pas monsieur
monsieur macron de banquier d'un employé
de banque
enfin employée de banque vous parlez pas
spécialement vous parlez de la banque
comment vont les banques européennes et
récemment enfin on a vu la goldman sachs
faire de mauvaise performance sur son
activité matières premières
les banques européennes elles vont super
bien il ya 350 milliards de dettes
pourris dans les banques italiennes
que dire
elles vont bien elles vont très très
bien et puis en plus elle se croit à
l'abri c'est le modèle bancaire c'est
probablement le plus beau monde le plus
beau modèle économique au monde
c'est le truc génial
c'est
fâcheux père qui fasse je gagne pile tu
perds donc c'est vraiment le modèle
parfait quand ça gagne c'est pour les
actionnaires et c'est pour les traders
qui se prennent des primes sympa un
puits pour le patron de la banque qui se
prend aussi des primes est sympa et puis
quand ça perd basse et pour le
contribuable ou c'est pour le déposant
maintenant donc c'est vraiment un modèle
magique pourquoi pour le déposant pas
parce que vous savez vous savez très
bien alors ccc ressorti récemment parce
qu'il ya une une alerte de reuters
disant que l'union européenne
était en train de plancher la dessus
pour rendre sa légal mais enfin ils
n'ont pas eu besoin d'un texte pour le
faire à chypre je vous le rappelle donc
et comme c'est eux qui font les textes
s'ils voulaient ils pourront bien le
faire après ce porte il principe simple
principe c'est et c'était de dire
le sien un pépin
en europe et c c'est assez logique siens
paie pas en europe dans une banque et
qu'on est obligé
de fermer cette banque un cyclone
bancaire non il ya simplement un un gros
pépin enfin rendez vous compte que il ya
trois banques qui ont sauté en italie
dont deux banques vénitienne que
personne ne connaissait que personne ne
connaissait qui était passé au travers
des stress tests des états
qui ont quand même qui coûte la
bagatelle de 17 milliards 17 milliards
c'est 1% du pib italien
donc imaginez le jour où ça va être dans
une grosse banque
est donc là on se retrouve devant
quelque chose qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas maîtrisable ni par l'état ni par
personne donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que vous serez amenés à fermer la
banque
si vous fermez la banque vous fermez les
autres banques parce que sinon le tout
les gens vont comprendre que la leur et
la suivante et donc ils vont il ya un
bank run qui est déclenché et non
seulement ça vous êtes obligé de le
faire dans votre pays le pays d'origine
du problème et vous êtes obligés de le
faire dans toute l'europe c'est parce
qu'ils sont pour chypre pourquoi non
parce que les gens n'ont pas compris et
puis parce que on vous a localisé ce à
chypre c'était un petit un petit
problème mais croyez moi si ça arrive en
italie ça va être autre chose et ça va
être autre chose ça va impliquer que on
ferme et on contrôle les capitaux dans
toute l'europe pourquoi parce que si
vous voyez la queue devant les banques
et les banques tout fermer en italie si
vous avez deux sous de jugeote qu'est ce
que vous faites ou précipité à votre
banque et vous allez chercher vos sous
donc ça veut dire que vous déclenchez de
fait un bank run dans toute l'europe est
donc le seul moyen ces deux bleus les
banques dans toute l'europe alors on
vous dit 20 jours le problème c'est que
fait ça pendant 20 jours vous les ouvrez
le 21e qu'est-ce qui se passe
vous allez chercher vos sous donc ça
durera plus de vingt jours et ensuite on
vous dit ah mais pas de panique un ça
sera pour des comptes au dessus de 100
mille mal ça dépend de la perte
ça détend de la perte ça dépend pas
d'autre chose il n'y a rien qui soit
gravé dans le marbre si la perte est
gigantesque
qu'est-ce qui se passe bah ils taperont
sur têt 50000 ils taperont / 20 minutes
après on sur 10000 on n'en sait rien
le leu leu leu ce qui avait été mis en
place sur
sur l'ajustement le fonds de secours des
banques c'est 2 milliards c'est
grotesque
c'est contre cette l'augmenter y compte
l'augmenter à 3 5 milliards si mesrine
heures sont montrés et alors ils
essayent et alors je vous dis 17
milliards sur deux banques mais fait de
deux minuscules banque en italie donc on
en est où là on fait quoi il essaye de
le monter leurs fonds et peut-être grâce
à ce fonds ils pourront aussi avoir un
effet de levier pour rassurer d'autres
personnes mais je veux aucun avocat
n'est pas sûr d vous rassure des sur les
mêmes sur les mêmes mi temps
vous avez en gros sur tout le système
bancaire européen
les fonds propres des banques
européennes souvent le majeur un société
générale bnp deutsche bank en allemagne
les banques toutes les banques
européennes c'est de l'ordre de 50
milliards je vous fais ça en très très
gros alors vous avez par exemple la bm
pc 70 milliards de fonds propres mais en
général c'est une cinquantaine de
milliards vous avez en face un un actif
total de la banque qui est autour d'eux
500 milliards de 2,2 d'actifs d'accord
donc déjà 50 milliards de fonds propres
1500 milliards d'actifs ok et vous avez
en le ce qu'on appelle les expositions
sur les produits dérivés
mondiaux sur absolument tous les
produits dérivés ça peut être matière
première ça peut être des comics a peut
être des actions ça peut être bon sur
tout ce qui est produits dérivés donc
hors bilan des banques là vous avez
quelque chose autour de 30 mille
milliards
d'euros à chaque fois d'accord
rendez vous compte alors je ne dis pas
que le risque et sur trente mille
milliards parce que je sais qu'on va
essayer de me reprendre là dessus le
risque n'est pas sur trente mille
milliards mais des économistes ont
calculé que sur trente mille milliards
d'exposition sur les marchés à terme
vous aviez en gros un risque sur 10 % ça
fait quand même trois mille milliards
d'accord donc ça fait par exemple la
danse que dans ce cas là une fois et
demi le pipe français
sur chaque banque
donc oublier les fonds avec 5 10 15
milliards de da parce que c'est juste
ridicule depuis un lit pas à la hauteur
du problème depuis 2008 les banques
centrales du mois la banque centrale
européenne a injecté combien dans le
système financier
la banque centrale européenne la banque
centrale européenne elle est là elle à
elle a commencé en termes de purement de
curieux je vous parle pas de tous
qu'elle avait mis en place qui était dlt
héros qui était quelque chose qui était
un petit peu plus
de mon point de vue en tout cas plus
intelligent que le quantitative easing
mai mais qui a été partiellement
remboursés et c'est donc mais le
quantitative easing l'aï là il a fait
80 milliards par mois
et ensuite la récemment il était il est
descendu à 60 mais le le truc qui est
extraordinaire c'est que on sait que ça
ne fonctionne pas un quantitative on a
les preuves de ça on a les preuves de sa
d'abord sur le japon on se fonctionne ça
fonctionne pour éviter que les banques
se casse la gueule non à court terme
mais non mais non mais non mais c'est
pas gestion c'est mal vu que je coure
bouillonnant fait on vous a dit quoi on
vous a dit on fait un quantitative
easing 1 pour relancer la croissance 2
pour relancer l'inflation d'accord et
soirée les banques n'ont pas ce que ça
vous aviez d'autres moyens pouviez faire
en effet ce qu'on avait fait un moment
c'est-à-dire à alterhéros parce que le
le but du jeu était de
2-2 donner accès aux banques de donner
accès à skis et ski avec collapse est
complètement en 2008 2009 c'est à dire
le marché interbancaire donc on leur a
donné la la banque centrale leur a mis à
disposition de l'argent pour parce
qu'elle avait peur de se prêter entre
elles bon ok ça ça a très bien
fonctionné ça a permis de soulager des
banques qui n'avaient plus accès à ce
marché interbancaire
là aujourd'hui c'est pas ça on vous fait
un
quantitative easing pour relancer
l'inflation et pour relancer
le
les économies or on sait que ça ne
fonctionne pas il ya même eu il n'ya pas
il n'ya pas très longtemps un rapport
d'une vingtaine de pages qui a été fait
par qui a été fait par la fête de saint
louis si mes souvenirs sont bons
justement
décortiquant ces phénomènes de 2 qe2
quantitative easing et disant que ça ne
fonctionnait pas prouvant que ça ne
fonctionnait pas on le sait on sait que
ça n'a absolument aucune influence sur
l'inflation et ça on le sait avec le
japon qui a fait on en est au 13e ou 14e
que quantitative easing donc on a un
petit peu de recul or ça n'a jamais
relancer l'inflation et puis sur le
quantitative easing l'effet du
quantitative easing sur la croissance
alors là c'est très simple on est allé
regarder ce qui s'est passé aux états
unis et ce qui s'est passé au canada au
canada il n'y a pas eu de quantitative
easing après la après la chute de 2008
il n'y a pas eu de quantitative easing
on regarde la croissance qui a eu aux
états unis avec quantitative easing et
la croissance qui a eu au canada sans
qui constituent le type d'économie mais
je suis désolé c'est quand même très
très lié très très très lié or
malheureusement qu'est ce qu'on voit ben
on voit que la croissance du canada est
bien supérieur à ce que à ce que vous
avez eus
aux états unis ça ne fonctionne pas et
ça ne peut pas fonctionner et je vais
vous dire pourquoi ça ne fonctionnera
pas sur l'inflation et ça ne
fonctionnera pas sur sur la croissance
comment croyez-vous que parce que une
banque centrale va acheter des
obligations le marché ça va relancer
quoi que ce soit expliquez-moi par quel
phénomène extraordinaire ça pourrait
relancer quelque chose ça pourrait faire
baisser le chômage à part le l'espèce de
dieu deux guignols qui vont embaucher
pour appuyer sur le bouton achat en
permanence excusez moi mais je vois pas
très bien par quel phénomène une banque
centrale qui achètent des oubliées qui
les stops dans son bilan ça va relancer
la croissance ça va relancer l'inflation
c'est l'argent qui ne circulent pas
c'est donc elle peut être le problème où
ça décale peut-être le problème ça
décale rien du tout ça ne sert à rien ça
ne sert à rien et pourtant c'est quand
même comme ça à cons et c'est non
seulement ça ne sert à rien mais c'est
pire que de ne rien faire ça leur porte
non ça reporte rien ça aggrave le
problème parce que il va falloir en
sortir de cette histoire or on voit
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont incapables d'en
sortir pourquoi est ce que mon amie
hélène recul si si tout va bien si ça
relancer la croissance si réellement
elle est en
taux
en plein emploi si réellement
elle a de suffisamment de croissance
auto entretenue et c'est pourquoi ne
montre tel passé tôt pourquoi ne
manque-t-elle pas ses taux pourquoi ça
fait trois ans qu'elle nous mène en
bateau et qu'elle nous dit ah oui enfin
bon là je vais peut-être attendre un peu
là vous allez voir avec le avec les
ouragans elle à son son sont sa raison
tout trouvé elle a son aile va se
défausser là dessus en disant ah bah oui
mais non mais là je remonte pas les taux
parce que il l'ouragan qui est passée
puis la semaine prochaine il fera froid
et puis qu'est ce qu'a pensé de la
devine la devise schumpétérienne qui est
la destruction créatrice
et c'est ce qu'on a évité c'est à dire
que en 2008 2009 au lieu de laisser
tomber les banques qui avaient fait des
bêtises au lieu de
2 d'avoir une très forte récession et et
de laisser les choses se faire on est
intervenu on est intervenu et donc on a
empêché la destruction
créatrice et aujourd'hui ça aboutit à ça
c'est à dire qu'on tient à bout de bras
des choses qui sont
absolument pas rentable on se réjouit
aux états unis parce que ce serait jouer
aux états unis parce que ils ont sauvé
general motors d'accord mais ils l'ont
trouvé comment aujourd'hui il ya une
dette abyssale
mais je dis bien abyssal sur les crédits
automobiles aux etats-unis et c'est une
bulle sa valeur péter à la figure
exactement comme les subprimes
dans l'immobilier aujourd'hui il ya de
plus en plus de défauts mais tout ce qui
leur importait c'était de vendre des
voitures peu importe ce qui faisait
comme comme comme argent là dessus et
donc on essaie de maintenir quelque
chose qui n'est pas
maintenable elle ça on l'a fait alors
nous connais bien en france ce genre de
process et ça se finit toujours comme ça
doit finir c'est à dire
en
liquidation et on a oui on a gagné
quelques années est alors au lieu
d'utiliser tout l'argent qu'on a mis
dans c dans ces boîtes là pour pour les
faire survivre est ce que vous pensez
pas que on aurait pu utiliser cet argent
pour former les gens pour qu'ils fassent
autre chose ça aurait été peut-être plus
intelligent non qu'est ce que vous
pensez des crypto monnaie
gens pensent que
[Musique]
ça m'amuse ça m'amuse de voir des gens
qui vont sur les crypto monnaie parce
qu'ils n'ont pas confiance
dans une dans l'âme dans leur monnaie
électronique parce que c'est aujourd'hui
c'est que sa
fille lui c'est ça oui et donc qu'ils
ont peur ils ont peur de détenir du
dollar ils ont peur de détenir de l'euro
ils ont peur de détenir et ils vont sur
un truc qui est un truc électronique
aussi bien je critique pas le la
mécanique la fiabilité la alors la
fiabilité il y à haradheere je pense
largement au dessus mais enfin ça pour
ça vous êtes plus experts que moi mais
eux
il y à il ya eu des cas quand même de
hacking de ce genre de process donc
c'est pas sûr c'est pas sûr toute façon
un truc électro n'est jamais sûr par
définition puisque
ceux qui ont de mauvaises intentions
toujours un coup d'avancé que
ça me paraît déjà
un peu un peu foireux à ce niveau là et
puis en plus si vous voulez quand je
vois le nombre de monnaie électronique
qui secret je me dis quelle valeur ce à
partir du moment où n'importe quel gars
un peu d'eau et en informatique va créer
sa petite monnaie de son côté qu'est ce
que ça vous savons rien par définition
donc excusez moi mais
que vous alliez
c'est ce que je conseille à mes clients
je leur dit écoutez si vous avez envie
de vous faire peur si vous avez envie de
d'avoir un grand frisson aller jouer sur
le bitcoin mais jouer c'est à dire comme
vous iriez au casino ne prenez pas ça
pour une
réserve
de votre patrimoine comme vous pouvez le
faire sur d'autres actifs réels
là c'est pas un actif réel c'est une
ligne de code et ça vaut ce que ça vaut
c'est à dire pas grand chose la
confiance peut être que les gens mettent
dedans
enfin jusqu'au jour où un
pays
où l'ensemble des pays tape du poing sur
la table et disent niet voilà ce jour là
c'est fini
ils peuvent le faire
tout faire c'est eux qui font les lois
je vous le rappelle passe compliquée
pour le bitcoin quand même d'en écouter
non pas tellement la chine a dit ça
suffit là ya pas très longtemps voilà
donc et regardez ce qui s'est passé on
peut pas vous pouvez pas qualifié de
monnaie un truc avec une volatilité
pareil
c'est pas sérieux je veux dire vous
allez peuple qui vous allez pouvoir
payer avec un truc qui peut se casser la
gueule de 50% dans une en une journée
personne n'avait accepté donc fini donc
c'est un support de trading mais pas
autre chose un support de trading hyper
spéculatifs c'est ça
quelles solutions pour ça alors c'est
une question qui vient de la communauté
quelle solution pour sortir du marasme
économique des préconisations la
décroissance qu'est ce que vous pensez
de la décroissance ou je crois pas que
ce soit la solution je crois que alors
oui et non
je crois qu'il ya un moment où il va
falloir qu'on arrête le espèce de en
revanche de surcroît sens de
surconsommation à tout prix qui est
franchement qui va vers le le grotesque
le système financier est peut-être
besoin c'est un an oui bien sûr
qui valent à qui a atteint des
proportions à mon avis grotesque moi ce
que je pense c'est que il faudrait
aujourd'hui
arrêté
le l'hyper spécialisation des pays parce
que je pense que c'est ça qui nous a
fichu dedans c'est à dire d'avoir des
modèles économiques
qui soient uniques comme je vous le
disais le japon qui était entièrement
exportateur l'allemagne qui est
entièrement exportatrices etc et
puis après aussi l'hyperspécialisation
c'est à dire que on est on se réjouit
tous aujourd'hui de d'avoir des des des
pays qui ne sont que fournisseur de
services et qui a plus d'industrie de
dents etc je pense que on devrait
plutôt essayé de s'orienter vers
de façon à ce que chaque pays soit quasi
autonome si vous voulez c'est à dire que
il est tout le spectre de de
l'industriel des industries de
l'alimentaire de
des services mais qui soit quasi
autonome et à ce moment là je pense que
déjà on aurait quelque chose qui aurait
plus de chances de
survivre plutôt que quelque chose qui
est hyper spécialisés donc si jamais il
ya un problème sur sur son modèle ce qui
est en train d'arriver au japon ces deux
régions c'est à dire plus de résilience
au niveau des états
bac +2 de huy d'autonomie et donc faire
revenir enfin s'arranger pour que
dans un pays vous ayez
un
modèle qui soit un modèle universel et
non pas spécialisés sur sur quelque
chose parce que là on arrive à des
dérapages
avec des déséquilibres qui secret quand
vous avez la chine qui était devenu l'
usine du monde et qui a fait exploser
les matières premières parce que elle en
avait besoin de beaucoup et tout ça
entraîne des déséquilibres et vous avez
pendant ce temps là les les la grosse
masse des chinois qui n'a pas de salaire
parce que ou des salaires très bas parce
que justement les entreprises qui vient
de s'installer pèse sur les salaires
pour pour augmenter leurs marges ecsta
on a un système qui ne peut aller que
vers la catastrophe et que
le le fait de faire en sorte que chaque
pays soit quasi autonome parce que vous
n'aurez jamais totalement une autonomie
me paraître plus viable que ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui six si le système
rentrer en décroissance si les gens
consomment moins que
les points de pib baisse un peu parce
qu'il met on arrête cette croix si vous
avez jarre est ce que le système
financier peut résister à ça non est-ce
que c'est peut-être pour ça qu'ils
continuent de baisser pour ça c'est
c'est la bête qui refuse de mourir
c'est pour ça bien sûr mais de toute
façon vous avez là aujourd'hui on est
dans des dans des pays qui sont matures
des pays qui vieillissent tous l'italie
l'espagne l'allemagne
alors nous on se réjouit parce que
on a de la natalité
je pense qu'il faudrait pas trop serait
joué regardez un tout petit peu plus en
détail ce qui se passe mais
aujourd'hui elle le simple fait d'avoir
des pays qui vieillit c'est ça vous
l'avez en chine aussi où la vue aux
états unis vous l'avez partout sur le
globe quand vous avez un pays qui
vieillit les modes de consommation
changent quand vous quand vous avez 60
70 ans vous ne consommez pas comme quand
vous en avez 25 ou 30 d'accor et puis en
plus ça pas être facile de consommer
puisque vous n'aurez plus de retraite
donc ça va être assez assez difficile
sur les sur les prochaines années donc
ça va être ça va être de plus en plus
compliqué de faire de la croissance vous
ne pourrez plus parce que vous avez des
gens regardent enfin on a un vrai
laboratoire vivant c'est le japon il a
20 ans ou 30 en avance sur nous c'est un
pays qui vieillit vous avez une
population qui diminue d'accord ils sont
aujourd'hui 126 millions 700 mille corps
ils seront
sans y seront moins de 90 millions en
2050 ils ont perdu un tiers de leur
population
donc
il faut tête se mettre à réfléchir sur
savoir ce qu'on veut comme modèle au
lieu d'aller nous dire comme le font les
politiques tous les ans ah oui mais
l'année prochaine ça ira mieux non ça
ira pas mieux parce que l'année
prochaine on aura pas rajeuni lincou
donc on va vers quelque chose à n'est
pas année par année on va vers un pays
où il y aura de plus en plus d'inactifs
de moins en moins d'actifs et donc ça
pose un vrai problème
qu'est-ce qu'il a sonné là à essayer de
avec des petits bouts de sparadrap
d'essayer de combler les le soleil
rogerson aubin on va peut-être passer
l'âge de la retraite de 62 63 c'est pas
le sujet le salaire universel non parce
que le salaire universel coc
une aussi
cesser ces gentilles et je trouve c'est
mignon comme idée voilà c'est mignon
salaires universel qu'il verse nous
impôt d'accor
donc ça veut dire que vous avez des
actifs qui vont reverser tous leurs
salaires n'ont peut-être de
l'intelligence artificielle ou des
robots qui seront axés
d'accord
de l'intelligence artificielle et des
robots et puis les gens qui les
construisent les voilà à lui failli
après ils vont se construire tout seul
et nous vous serez infectés tranquille
puis les robots et l'intelligence
artificielle ça ça fait quoi ça bouffe
ça s'habille ça ça fait quoi sa part en
vacances non ça prend un emploi un de
ceux qui ont souscrit des prêts
étudiants d'accord voilà donc non enfin
il faut être faut être sérieux il ya un
moment où moi je veux bien le revenu
universel mais faut le prendre à
quelqu'un c'est un truc de
redistribution d'accord donc il ya bien
il ya bien des gens qui vont gagner de
l'argent pour le payer ce revenu
universel
et il se trouve qu'il y en a de moins en
moins et donc qu'il y aura de plus en
plus de gens qui auront un revenu
universel et qui ne travailleront pas et
puis de moins en moins de gens pour les
payer donc à excusez moi mais il ya un
truc qui mathématiquement marche pas
donc voilà alors si c'est pour
après appelé revenu universel ce que ce
qui pour l'instant est le cas vous
versez en rsa rmi et machins et
l'appeler par un seul nom
super
l'économie l'économie du partage ça vous
parle
oui ça me parle
[Musique]
cc c'est surtout
je pense aujourd'hui
ça commence déjà par l'économie du du
troc de plus en plus on voit ça beaucoup
en amérique du nord canada et compagnie
ou vous avez de plus en plus de gens qui
troque des services contre un autre
c'est une façon de sortir de l'impôt pas
c'est une façon de 1 de sortir de
l'impôt et puis c'est une
c'est une façon aussi
de
de se passer
de transactions
[Musique]
monétaires
notre question de la communauté quelle
solution sur la corruption et l'évasion
fiscale solutions mondiales pour
l'interrogation
sur l'évasion fiscale il faudrait mettre
quand même un petit
une petite précision c'est que souvent
on vous parle de l'évasion fiscale en
vous disant
en vous parlant de des quelques
particuliers qui ont mis leurs sous à
l'abri en suisse ou ailleurs
c'est pas ça à l'évasion fiscale s'est
pas c'est pas le le gars qui a réussi
parce que il en avait marre de se faire
éponger par le fisc qui a réussi à
mettre deux cent mille balles de côté
sur un compte en suisse la vraie évasion
fiscale c'est pas ça la vraie l'évasion
fiscale c'est je vous rappelle un pays
qui était un un caillou avec des moutons
dessus qui s'appelle l'irlande 1 qu'on a
mis dans l'europe et à qui on a mis
comme modèle économique s'il en avait
pas donc c'était un pays pauvres à qui
on a mis comme modèle économique que les
entreprises qui viendraient s'installer
chez eux auraient entre 6 et 8 pour son
impôt et peut-être même moins d'ailleurs
si elle négocie bien ce qui fait que au
sein de l'europe
mis en place par l'europe on a un pays
qui est un centre d'évasion fiscale pour
toutes les boîtes du monde ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que aujourd'hui les
boîtes du cac 40
elle ne paye pas comme une pme vous vous
monter une entreprise demain vous monter
une petite une petite entreprise une
sarl une une sas vous allez être imposée
à 30% d'accor
et puis quand vous prendrez du dividende
vous allez être à nouveau imposé
d'accord et une grande entreprise une
entreprise comme total ou ce genre de
deux boîtes qui peuvent se permettre
d'aller mettre des des filiales et de
passer par l'irlande ils vont payer au
total sur leurs sur leurs résultats 7 8%
d'accord pas 33 donc cela elle et
l'évasion fiscale et la sa porte sur des
centaines de milliards les solutions et
pas du tout d'aller emmerder le pauvre
type qui a réussi à mettre deux cent
mille balles quand c'est lui d'ailleurs
parce que quand c'est pas ses parents ou
où ses arrières grands parents les
solutions passent culte aux états
pratiquent les mêmes choses ils font du
dumping fiscal des états unis où leur
propre petit paradis fiscal pour tout le
monde y est nous qui
la gêne on m'annonce mais celui-ci ne
faisons rien je veux dire au moment où
les irlandais parce qu'en 2008 a chuté
en fin en 2009 a chuté quand quand les
banques irlandaises ont sauté
il fallait à ce moment-là revenir sur le
modèle en disant mais côté on veut on
rétablit le taux avait pas du tout parce
que sinon on savait que l'irlande
probablement serait sorti de l'eau donc
ou la non on leur ont leur maintien leur
modèle donc on n'a pas du tout envie que
à quoi c'est du chantage à l'emploi
c'est du chantage à l'évasion fiscale
c'est du sens et du cc non ses chances
d'un règlement par qui part qui sont
financés les politiques par les grandes
entreprises
sont pas du tout évident de se fâcher
que tout le monde se tient par la
barbichette la wii tout le monde dont le
premier qui rend une qu'est-ce
qui va rire en premier votre avis
j'ai peur que ce soit eux et que nous on
en prend plein c'est nous qui allons
prendre une a pris une grosse je
pense une grosse qui va se matérialiser
comment
je vous dis par
probablement
un éclatement de banque à un moment ou
un autre
parce que statistiquement ça va arriver
que ce jour là sera pas maîtrisable que
on arrivera à bloquer les comptes et à
rétablir un contrôle des capitaux
bloquer les comptes comme en argentine
ou autres qu'à ce moment là on aura
la monnaie qui s'effondrera et et je
pense que on va avoir la des grosses
difficultés qui font passer les
différents crack qu'on a eu pour des
plaisanteries le problème c'est si vous
voulez c'est que les gens se s'axe sur
sur le ski voie de la bourse parce
qu'aujourd'hui les quantitative easing
ils ont réussi une chose ils ont fait
monter les bourses ça c'est indéniable
d'accord donc ils ont augmenté le prix
des actifs
mais si vous n'avez pas de portefeuilles
boursiers ce qui est le cas de beaucoup
en france vous avez vous n'avez pas
grand chose vous l'avez pas vu l'effet
du cul et donc
vous avez ce quantitative easing qui ne
peut se terminer que mal c'est à dire
par une destruction de la valeur de la
monnaie alors souvenez-vous de ce qui
s'est passé en argentine sa vaste ap ah
bah après sa star oui oui après ça de
simples gens façon cyclone
on voit ce que ça on voit le l'absolu
impuissance de l'état
à saint-martin et
autres vous la verrez
probablement
en france et en
métropole quoi parce que
c'est aujourd'hui il a il a quand même
il a quand même décapité l'armée quand
il est arrivé monsieur macron il a viré
son son chef d'état-major
jeu près sûr que l'armée soit tout à
fait réjouit de cette chose là un de ces
jours ça pourrait bien lui revenir dans
le dans les naseaux
alors autre question que pensez vous des
monnaies locales alternative
c'est la même chose que les crypto
monnaie c'est s'aider crypto monnaie en
général
il ya une alternative pourquoi c'est
bien c'est bien parce que les gens
croient que le système bon ils croient
plus au système est soi-disant
ils tiennent ils tiennent à l'euro mais
pourquoi est ce que il se réveille pas
sachant que l'euro est une absolue
bêtise donc j'en viens au deuxième
question que peut-on faire nous en tant
que citoyens
ce que vous pouvez faire pas grand chose
parce que dans le système actuel à part
ceux se révolter
physiquement je dirais n'y a pas grand
chose y'a pas grand chose à faire
monsieur bah kron a été élu avec quoique
14% de la population 15% de la
population donc qu'est ce que vous
pouvez faire
rien allez tous déposé un bulletin blanc
la prochaine fois ci si vous n'avez pas
envie mais à la limite même s'il y en
avait 3 et le second 1 il serait élu
donc dans le système actuel il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas grand chose malheureusement
à faire alors après vous pouvez si en
revanche vous pouvez vous protéger et
faire en sorte de 2,2
dont prendre le moins dans la figure
possibles le jour où ça arrivera il ya
des choses à faire
mais mais qui sont pas non plus garanti
parce que parce que vous avez face à
vous un état qui sera acculé donc qu'il
sera dangereux chose à faire part des
choses à faire il faut il faut en effet
ne pas faire confiance à à son banquier
ne pas faire confiance
dans des assurances vie qui sont des
trucs de plus en plus pourri c'était une
très bonne idée il ya quinze ans ça
allait pas aujourd'hui et donc c'est
dangereux et bien on prendre conscience
dire ne croyez pas que sous prétexte que
vous avez 95 mille euros sur votre
compte vous êtes à l'abri c'est pas vrai
et ne croyez pas que
parce que vous avez une assurance vie
vous êtes à l'abri tout et que vous
allez continuer à
gagner de l'argent
avec une avec votre argent en toute
sécurité qui vous sera rendu c'est pas
vrai non plus voilà notre dernière
question avant de passer la géopolitique
quels sont vos utopie dans quelle
organisation sociale souhaiteriez-vous
vivre après l'effondrement si
effondrement il
est question d'internet oui
j'aimerais convives tous avec des
petites fleurs dans les cheveux
avec un beau soleil au bord de la mer à
elle de belles femmes
bon enfin je veux dire ce que ce que
j'aimerais c'est 6,6 en effet
comme je le pense le le système
s'effondre
qui est un sacré ménage un sacré ménage
au niveau politique a sacré ménage au
niveau
au niveau des instances économiques
parce que parce que ça va pas parce que
il fonde et ils vivent entre eux sur des
modèles qui sont totalement
dépassés ils se raccrochent à des
modèles je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué c'est assez assez amusant à
chaque fois que vous entendez un
économiste is eux ils se réfèrent à des
économistes morts
puis mort pape à poil hier mort il ya 60
ans en disant 80 ans et donc en vous
disant ce que ce gars là a pondu il ya
soixante dix ans mais il ya 70 ans on
n'était pas du tout dans le même monde
ça n'avait rien à voir et donc ces
modèles sont complètement dépassés mais
complètement donc
et il faut toujours
collé une étiquette
alors moi je suis allé faire des
conférences dans des écoles dans les
universités et à chaque fois vous avez
des élèves qui vient de me voir vous
êtes de quelle école économique
mais voilà parce que on peut pas penser
par soi même en france où il faut
automatiquement qu'on est un modèle ou
faut qu'on ait une école de pensée mais
mes pensées soi même ça ça n'existe pas
c'est quand même assez amusant passé
l'âge et au bout
la russie
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de la russie
est ce qu'elle a fait son job avec la
syrie et l'a pas fait son job avec assia
laisse moi c'est parce que
c'est le sionisme
soit allée des revenues en partie parce
que la russie attisent les tensions
bien sûr que non je trouve je le trouve
même
excessivement patients
c'est
excessivement patients je pense que
c'est à peu près le seul le soldat qui
soit aujourd'hui le seul le seul
président
qu'ils soient bien dans son costume
macron il a enfilé un costume qui est
trois tailles au dessus
et ils savent où pour à peu près trump
j'en parle même pas et donc non je pense
que c'est le seul type qui fasse le taf
quoi trump
un treuil états unis trump en fait c'est
le le problème c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est que
à propos de macron qui était président
de vrai du tout qui était une
marionnette agité par par madame merkel
trump il est agité que par qui part par
les néo cons qui ont repris qui ont
repris la main
sitôt l'élection
donc trump on lui file un texte qui le
lie avec plus ou moins de classer et
plutôt moins que plus et puis et puis
voilà c'est un acteur maintenant entre
hommes puis décide de rien colleen
larose ont corée du nord
corée du nord moi j'ai tendance à à dire
que c'est un c1 c'est un demeuré
pacy de vrai que ça fasse et 1,2 me réel
quand rien du nord ça fait ça fait quand
même un moment que c'est un c'est un
système qui
qui est
probablement un des pires sur la planète
et le gars il fait tout pour pour
conserver son truc moi je j'ai tendance
quand même à me méfier de jouer au
concours de celui qui pisse le plus loin
parce que c'est la cour d'école on a
l'impression de l'extérieur que il ya
deux il ya deux dungy a trompé
kim jong il kim jong
est qui et qui joue avec avec des jouets
qui qui sont qui sont quand même assez
effrayant donc voila moi je suis pas je
suis pas pour
continuer ces jeux là et je pense que
une interview de poutine ya pas très
longtemps où
il paraissait raisonnable et où il
disait faut arrêter ce ce jeu et ne pas
rentrer justement dans cette dans cette
espèce de concours qui peut se finir
très mal donc de calmer le jeu de
laisser les choses retombées plutôt que
déclarations après déclaration essayer
de
d'allumer la mèche la chine
la chine face aux états unis la chine
face à ces revendications sur la mer de
chine mais sa politique en neuf très
là aussi ça se finira ça se finira le
problème c'est que la chine
économiquement
n'en est pas du tout là où elle en était
il ya il ya il ya une quinzaine d'années
le la chine c'était un deal c'était un
deal entre eux entre
l'état
chinois
tous plus ou moins milliardaire je vous
le rappelle
et qui
avait un deal avec le reste de la
population chinoise en disant
voilà
on va faire de la croissance nous on va
se gaver
vraiment
et puis vous vous aurez les miettes sauf
que les miettes de d'une croissance à
deux chiffres si vous voulez c'est quand
même de très jolis miettes bon le
problème c'est que pour plein de raisons
des raisons cycliques des raisons de
d'erreur de pilotage économies qui sont
lancés dans un plan d'investissement qui
était juste ahurissant avec une dette
qui est monté à la verticale enfin c'est
c'est
alors bien sûr tout le monde en a
profité puisque sa satire est fort
mais c'est le japon x 10 voilà c'est à
peu près le même le même scénario
d'ailleurs ils sont aussi avec leur
politique d'enfants uniques ils sont en
train de 2 de la population est en train
de virer normalement j'aurais tessin il
aura été sa non
merci il faut que ça aille fort donc
lors leur politique fait que le pays vit
énormément
et puis ils ont
ils ont surinvesti
souvenez-vous des des villes mortes
complètement en prévention et en déroute
qui ne mènent nulle part des aéroports
vide enfin bon
donc ils ont dépensé beaucoup d'argent
alors on dit toujours s'élancer le tout
les communes je vous dis ouais mais ils
ont des réserves de changes
extraordinaire ha ouais ils ont d'abord
les et réserves de change ont fondu
comme neige au soleil là ils sont passés
en dessous de 3000 milliards et il faut
voir la dette enfin c'est juste
hallucinant et donc vous avez la
croissance qui a diminué alors le
problème c'est qu'on sait pas c'est à
dire que ils vous donnent des chiffres
il vous donne des chiffres à 6 mais ils
peuvent vous donner cette le lendemain
si ça les amuse
quand vous regardez quand même vraiment
ce qu'ils se les autres chiffres ceux
qui sont pas trafic abl si vous voulez
sur l'énergétique y sont ils sont
probablement
passé pas très loin de zéro à un moment
dans l'est dans les trois années qui
précèdent ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que les miettes elles sont
nettement moins je lire et donc
hélas les gros ont pris peur et vous
avez assisté notamment l'année dernière
à une fuite des capitaux
hallucinante en chine ça sortait tous
les jours et dans des proportions
phénoménales et donc
ça prouve que ils sont conscients que ça
pourrait bardet à un moment où le fait
qu'ils soient là la chine le faire plus
ça veut dire que la chine ne tirent plus
alors là ils ont lancé un plan
d'investissement
sa satire ponctuellement mais les
déséquilibres sont là les créances
pourries sont là la dette abyssale elle
est là et elle est là pour longtemps et
donc qu' il faut pas croire que la chine
va être la locomotive du monde dans
l'est dans l'est dans l'émoi dans les
mois les années le fait que la chine
souhaite
acheté en juin de son pétrole
c'est le mouvement qu'on a depuis depuis
déjà plusieurs depuis déjà plusieurs
années vous savez de deux pays qui
conclut des swaps de devises
sûres pour leurs échanges
en général pétroliers mais mes autres
aussi la russie l'a fait
vous avez des yeux l'un cherche un peu
non oui bah vous avez fait tout le monde
tout le monde essaie de se dé dollars
hier soir que de toute façon le fait de
de faire tourner la planche à billets
aux états unis comme on l'a fait tourner
depuis des années
va se terminer
probablement mal ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire probablement un changement de
système monétaire mondial
un changement de système monétaire
mondial
ça veut dire quoi ça ça implique le fait
que
certains pays qui s'y préparent en ont
marre de se faire rançonner par les
états unis et donc cherche à
passer par par par d'autres par d'autres
moyens pourquoi aussi est ce que la
chine achète tout ce qu'elle peut comme
mort physique tout simplement parce que
elle se dit qu'un jour
quand y quand ils arriveront à la table
de négociation pour
justement
imaginer le nouveau système monétaire
elle aura plus de biscuits que les
autres à mettre sur la table
on va passer aux dernières questions
conseil pour les jeunes générations
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire nous les
jeunes devant eux les jeunes maintenant
je sais pas la révolution
[Rires]
[Musique]
je pense que on
leur prépare pas un monde sympathique et
accueillant
donc on fait quoi
donc on fait quoi donc déjà on fait bien
attention quand
quentin rigolos se présente à la
présidence
et puis et puis on
on se manifeste autant qu'on peut on
cherche d'abord à s'informer à
essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe et
essayer de comprendre ce que oui il nous
emmène c'est le but de ce genre
d'initiatives mais
il faut je moi je suis effaré de voir
que beaucoup de gens comprennent pas ce
qui est en train de se passer
économiquement et mondialement est donc
déjà déjà le le le
le faire savoir c'est déjà quelque chose
d'intéressant donc continuer je regarde
mes acolytes acolytes vous avez des
questions non non mais bon on va
annoncer la prochaine émission qui va se
passer aujourd'hui en direct à 14h avec
philippe pascot sur la corruption
politique
s'est rangé une dernière petite question
à propos de m
et donc n'oubliez pas 14 heures philippe
pascot dernière question les
econoclastes
les econoclastes c'est ça c'est
justement s'est essayée d'informer les
gens
et de ne pas de ne pas les laisser aux
mains de quelques organes de presse qui
leur racontent ce qu'ils veulent bien
leur raconter donc on essaie on essaie
de faire des conférences on essaie
d'informer les gens et de leur montrer
qu'il ya peut-être une autre façon de
voir les choses il ya peut-être une
autre façon de lire les choses et
pour qu'ils se fassent peut-être de
moins en moins en fumée je me fais
l'avocat du diable parce que étant donné
que syncsort view fait partie et membre
fondateur d econoclaste on va faire
l'avocat du diable on est tous d'accord
dans les econoclastes ou pas noront est
ce que c est ce qu on s'en remet un peu
plein la tête quand on n'est pas
d'accord oui mais il faut venir nous
voir quand on a nos nos déjeuners qu'
on était un peu en roue libre
surtout à la fin du déjeuner à fin du
déjeuner on se gêne pas pour
pour parler vrai que parler vrai nom le
but le but d econoclaste c'est pas
d'avoir quinze personnes qui sont
d'accord entre elles et qui n'ont c'est
d'essayer de montrer que il ya d'autres
façons de
lire qu'il faut lien entre les lignes
qu'il faut pas se faire avoir alors
évidemment sur sur beaucoup de choses on
se rejoint parce que il se trouve que si
on bosse un peu ce qui est pas le cas de
tout le monde puisque on est tous des
feignants selon monsieur macron mais si
on bosse un peu
eh bien on quand on on creuse on
s'aperçoit que on nous masque où on nous
en jolis vins peu la réalité donc voila
et là dessus on est d'accord c'est des
chips et des chiffres donc on arrive à
se mettre d'accord maintenant sur des
solutions sur sur certains excès des uns
ou des autres on peut ne pas être
d'accord oui tout à fait olivier
delamarche merci
merci merci à vous
[Musique]